[Music]
what would get an actor banned from a
talk show well don't touch that dial
we're about to count down a list of
banned actors and get into just what
went to Rye from inebriation to
interjection to altercation
in the 1990s Vivica A fox was a major
star she hasn't been part of a
blockbuster hit in decades but she's
more than capable of a comeback at any
time except on Jimmy Kimmel Live
following a bitter Feud with its host
that got her band as a guest it all
started in 2005 when Fox appeared on
Kimmel's late night show during his
usual Snappy Joe played an introduction
of the former Soul Food Star Kimmel made
a crack about one of Fox's close friends
The View host Star Jones in an awkward
and uncomfortable interview Fox pushed
back at Kimmel's insults you know I'm a
ride or die chick you're not going to
talk about my sister in an attempt to
salvage the interview Kimmel argued that
jokes go both ways but Fox wasn't
pleased and ultimately walked off the
stage Midway through
speaking to Bravo host Andy Cohen nearly
a decade later Kimmel said he banned Fox
from the show after that and even
suggested she may have been using drugs
during her appearance this didn't sit
well with Fox for obvious reasons and
the two have been at odds ever since
in the mid-2000s Dax Shepard was an
up-and-comer appearing in slacker
comedies like Employee of the Month
idiocracy and let's go to prison
guilty as hell he finally cleaned
himself up after a struggle with
substance abuse but before he got sober
Shepard was banned from one of the
biggest late night shows during an
appearance on the podcast the pursuit of
healthiness Shepard talked about a 2004
interview he did on Late Night with
Conan O'Brien while he was at a
particularly low Point admitting I had
done the pre-interview in a blackout and
I woke up to the hotel security shaking
me awake after being rushed to the set
of the show a disastrous interview with
host Conan O'Brien ensued you know what
yeah
Shepard recalled I don't know what he's
talking about I can tell he's cueing me
up for stories I've told but I don't
know any of the stories so I'm just
doing what I can to be funny out there
and I'm a mess so I was banned from that
show for some years until I got sober
since getting clean the actor has
appeared on Conan's TBS show many more
times
as Star Trek's Captain James T Kirk
William Shatner went boldly where no man
had gone before but while Kirk could
defeat alien entities vengeful Mad Men
and Klingon Warlords he met his match in
the form of Tonight Show host Johnny
Carson
tonight's show guests were banned for
giving controversial interviews being
belligerent and combative or even for
being under the influence but Shatner
was apparently given the heave hoe for
not being able to shut up he came clean
in his 2011 Memoir Shatner rules your
guide to understanding the Shatner Furs
and the World At Large in a particularly
Lively passage about his adventures in
talk show land Shatner writes I was even
banned from Carson after a mid-1980s
appearance where I talked too much and
monopolized our discussion it seems some
of these talk show hosts prefer to be
the ones who get all the laughs Shatner
returned to the series years later after
Carson retired British icon Hugh Grant
was nominated for best actor Emmys in
2020 and 2019 for his roles in Prestige
dramas a very English Scandal and the
undoing but while his recent success on
the small screen has garnered Immaculate
there was a time when he was a bigger
name on the big screen particularly
after his leading role in the classic
rom-com Four Weddings and a funeral
however despite his worldwide celebrity
Grant was banned from The Daily Show in
2001 as reported by Third beat at the
time then host Jon Stewart appeared at a
charity fundraiser and talked about
banning Grant he described a frustrating
appearance during which Grant complained
about the clip they were using from his
recent film describing him as the worst
guest they'd ever had Stewart said he's
giving everyone the whole time and he's
a big pain in the ass and we've had
dictators on the show in 2012 Grant
actually admitted he was wrong in a
Twitter confession writing turns out my
inner crab got the better of me
unforgivable J Stewart correct to give
me kicking in the 1980s Pop Star Madonna
was known for her controversial hits
such as like a virgin and papa Don't
Preach but it wasn't her music that got
her on British talk show host Pierce
Morgan's Blacklist in a 2011 interview
with Access Hollywood Morgan made it
clear that his acrimony towards the
Queen of Pop was personal and described
what he called a series of crimes
against him Morgan told host Billy Bush
a few things have gone down between
Madonna and I she knows Morgan claims
his animosity began years ago explaining
there was a bread roll throwing incident
in London in the mid 90s there was an
incident at the Cannes Film Festival
involving a photographer and a bodyguard
there's been an incident involving a pub
owned by her ex-husband guy Richie
apparently Morgan hasn't forgiven the
pop star in 2023 he tweeted I think
Madonna's become the biggest
cringe-making Fiasco in World
entertainment
Piers Morgan seems to have a problem
with almost everyone in Hollywood
another Target of his ire is Frasier
star Kelsey Grammer though this time it
might be understandable while his feuds
with other celebs stem from personal
dislike Morgan's reason for Banning
grammar has its roots in an appearance
the sitcom star made in 2012.
um I didn't like him grammar was to
appear on Piers Morgan Live but wasn't
happy when the show used an image of his
ex-wife Camille dunatachi in the opening
grammar and donatachi had a troubled
relationship and divorced in 2010 while
he'd been booked as the featured guest
when the time came grammar was a no-show
this isn't going to work Morgan tweeted
I like Kelsey Grammer personally but
this was a shockingly unprofessional
thing to do I wasn't even going to
mention his ex-wife as a result of the
incident Morgan publicly banned grammar
from the show late night talk shows have
spawned plenty of famous fights back in
the 80s then host of The Tonight Show
Johnny Carson famously held a grudge
against comedian Joan Rivers Rivers
first appeared on The Tonight Show in
1965. in the 1980s she became the de
facto host anytime Johnny Carson needed
a night off but things were never the
same after Rivers became the host of her
own top shell in a CNN segment aired
after her death in 2014. rivers recall
telling Carson about her new show saying
Brooks came with this amazing offer and
we took it and he was the first one I
called and as I said he hung up
apparently an unhappy Carson ended their
friendship from then on Rivers was
banned from The Tonight Show a
Prohibition that continued even when Jay
Leno took over in a 2014 interview with
Access Hollywood Leno explained I didn't
want to do it while Johnny was alive out
of respect Leno's successor Jimmy Fallon
ended the ban in time for rivers to make
a triumphant final appearance just
before her death
while there are plenty of celebrities
and actors who were banned by hosts of a
single talk show controversial comedian
Kathy Griffin says she's been banned
from several in fact she's proud of the
reason she's been prohibited from the
likes of the talk across the line what
line in 2022 Griffin told her Twitter
followers she'd been banned thanks to
her vocal criticism of CBS chairman Les
moonves throwing her weight behind
allegations of sexual assault that had
dogged him for years she was also
embargoed from David Letterman's show in
the 1990s and remains persona non grata
at the view but that's still not the end
of it Griffin's ongoing battle with
Ellen DeGeneres left her Uninvited if
not formally banned sparked by Griffin's
defense of Joan Rivers the two wound up
nearly at each other's throats with
vitriol apparently hurled both ways
The Walking Dead's Chopper riding
crossbow wielding Daryl Dixon is one of
the few characters to live through the
entire Series in fact he's set for a
spin-off yet the actor who plays him
Norman Reedus has at least one Nemesis
radio talk show host Howard Stern who
read his claims refuses to have him on a
show on John bernthal's podcast real
ones redis a huge Stern fan lamented the
ban and claimed not to know what was
behind it according to Bernthal Stern's
dislike of Rita's likely stems from an
encounter the actor had with the talk
show host's wife Beth ostrosky who
happens to be a big fan of the actor
Stern suggested there was some kind of
flirtation between ostrosky and Reedus
but Reedus denies it by Rita's account
he only chatted with Stern's wife over
their mutual love of cats but Bernthal
thinks Stern's obsessed with their
meeting and as a result wants nothing to
do with Rita's Dax Shepard isn't the
only guest Band by host Conan O'Brien
comedian and Howard Stern colleague
Artie Lange was banned because Conan and
network Executives were concerned he
might be relapsing into drug abuse
Ling was confused at being denied a
guest spot on late night after two
previous appearances telling the daily
news I am sober I can't be a third guest
I mean I'm not asking to bump George
Clooney but the band didn't last forever
in 2012 Lang appeared as a guest on
Conan on TBS where O'Brien made clear
that past treatment of Lang was out of
nothing but concern for his health
the late comedian Gilbert Gottfried was
known for his wacky off-the-wall Persona
and silly voice
he gets the internet to hate me right
away all right well we're well on our
way tonight he played iconic roles in
Aladdin and Problem Child but his
younger fans weren't aware of his filthy
side Gottfried actually had an entire
comedy album titled dirty jokes but it
wasn't his vulgarity that got him banned
by Howard Stern in fact it's still a bit
of a mystery why Gottfried's longtime
friend Howard Stern refused to have him
on as a guest for years
none other than Artie Lange confirmed
that Gottfried was banned announcing it
on Twitter in 2018. Lang suggested it
may have been because Gottfried wasn't a
popular draw While others believe it
started in 2010 when Godfrey jokingly
spit in a couple of cupcakes meant for
Stern Show staffers after his interview
then dared crew members to eat them
Godfrey passed away in 2022 so unless
Stern is willing to open up about just
what happened between them this is one
band that may forever remain a mystery
it seems that Tonight Show host Johnny
Carson had a tendency to hold a grudge
in addition to Joan Rivers and William
Shatner Everybody Loves Raymond star
Brad Garrett also got on his bad side
Garrett was banned from The Tonight Show
after defying orders to alter the
material in his stand-up routine I told
Tommy news in my sperm bigger than him
not funny but but true as a result he
was never invited back proving there was
a steep price to pay for crossing Johnny
Carson that's not the only controversy
Garrett stirred up on the show according
to his book when the balls drop how I
learned to get real and embrace life's
second half Garrett defied house orders
and did an impression of guest host Bill
Cosby that Drew last from the audience
but a cold stare from Cosby himself
if you or anyone you know is struggling
with addiction issues help is available
visit the Substance Abuse and Mental
Health Services Administration website
or contact samhsa's National helpline at
1-800-662-help 1-800-662-4357
[Music]